valorent has been Kinda Crazy Lately BCT
playoffs just wrapped up worldwide and
we now know all 12 teams who will be
attending Masters Tokyo there were
plenty of upsets some reverse sweeps and
some incredible plays but after nine
weeks of non-stop valorent was it too
much
[Music]
all right so before I get into
everything VCT I just want to remind you
to like the video subscribe to the
channel and turn on notifications that
way you won't miss the next time that
I'm back here talking about Valerie
which will probably just be next week
because there are so many games there's
been no shortage of valorent these past
couple months and this past week was
insane as someone who literally covers
the game for a living it was hard even
for me to keep up so for all the Casual
viewers out there let me quickly get you
up to speed in America's EG shocked
everyone and stole c9's Tokyo spot but
demon 1 looked bummed out because he
doesn't have a passport to even attend
the event then loud and NRG met in yet
another grand final and the Brazilians
swept them to become the inaugural
Champions over in emea foot and Navi
qualified but the real surprise was
Liquid taking down fnatic in the grand
finals with redgar going 18-8 and
opening duels as the team's igl and
controller player lastly T1 qualified as
the third seed in the Pacific region
before paper Rex pulled off an
incredible reverse sweep against DRX in
the grand finals and something out on
Arena yeah it was a lot playoffs
definitely delivered and even though I'm
sad that that C9 didn't qualify for
Tokyo it was cool to see teams like EG
liquid and T1 really hit their stride
but it was a grueling nine weeks for all
30 partner teams they had to play one
match every single week before jumping
straight into playoffs and some teams
then had to play five more series some
of which were even best of fives FNS
even tweeted after the grand finals and
said that this season took everything
out of them and he even questioned why
there's a five month break following
Champions booster agreed and added that
he wished there was at least a
mid-season brick I think that both of
these complaints are pretty reasonable
the time between lock-in and champions
only spanned seven months leaving five
months for the game changers world
championship and any third-party events
but as someone who comes from
traditional Sports and primarily keeps
up with the Premier League five months
is a long time I usually only have to
wait half that amount of time to watch
United suit up again and in just five
months valorent can change drastically
Riot loves to shake things up with new
agents maps and weapon balancing so with
a lengthy break we might not even get
the chance to see some of these new
metas develop I do think it's important
to have an off season and maybe give
tier 2 teams more events to compete in
but we still have no idea what those
events might look like overall this
season has felt crammed and even as
someone who has watched valorent
non-stop since the beta dropped three
years ago it sometimes feels like too
much during playoffs I could wake up and
watch 12 plus hours of valorent each and
every day across all three regions I
loved it but I can't imagine what it's
like for casual fans trying to keep up
with their favorite teams and they must
be nearly impossible for them to pay any
attention to the other regions balance
head of global Esports Leo Faria has
commented on the off season in the past
on the wise men podcast and plot chat
and here's what he had to say both times
admittedly we haven't put a lot of
effort into the off season yet and we
definitely want to do more I know we
have a quite long which honestly I call
quite healthy off-season because one
the reality is we want to give fans the
opportunity to miss the sport right when
people say I miss Valor that's a good
thing right we want to give people that
opportunity because then when the
competition when the season is on
it just feels that much more special he
went on to add that Riot wants to try
new things in the off season and maybe
even host events where partnered teams
can compete against Challengers rosters
and I think that would be pretty dope we
don't often see events like this in
franchise Esports but luckily Valerian
isn't franchised Riot are the ones
supporting these teams and if anything
it'll just help bring more eyes to the
tier 2 scene sure it was just a
pre-season event but it was cool
watching the guard play against partner
teams at the Tarik Ludwig Invitational
so I hope we maybe see more of that but
even if we do five months is still an
insanely long off season especially
after lock-in already replaced what
could have been a second Masters event
teams definitely need some sort of
off-season to relax and make roster
changes but five months I still think
it's too much luckily next year will
feature two splits so I think that will
help break things up and prevent some of
the burnout that players and fans might
currently be experiencing as of today
we're only 12 days away from the start
of Masters Tokyo fnatic liquid PRX and
Loud have already qualified for the
playoffs but for everyone else they're
right back to playing starting June 11th
but if you're addicted to valorent like
myself and you're wondering what to do
in the meantime well luckily Challengers
playoffs starts this week worldwide so I
guess I'll just be watching valorent
until the end of August
yeah instead of like having everything
in within like seven months so I think
doing like maybe within like nine months
would be good and then giving like a
three month off season like like what
the Premier League does basically
because yeah you can you can still host
events like uh an international break
where all the bathroom players go off
and represent their countries and yeah
allowing the best ones the wrestling get
like a nice little break for a week and
the fans get great for a week yeah I
mean a lot of people have talked about
like a valorant World Cup and I think
that would be cool